Oh,
see,
she's with you young
Chennai.
The Star Wars Saga is set against the backdrop of an intergalactic struggle
between the forces of light and
dark.
There are a fantastic alien worlds ethic,
space battles and cryptic ancient prophecies,
but at their core,
George Lucas's six star wars films are really coming of age story about boys
becoming men.
Both Luke and antiquing Skywalker begin their respective trilogies as wide eyed
idealistic young men eager to explore the universe.
They both leave their sheltered lives to embark on a journey of self discovery
that takes them to the farthest reaches of the galaxy and their adventures
ultimately usher them from adolescence into manhood and although their narrative
arcs and in wildly different ways,
both are guided and shaped by the principles of the Jetta Thousand Generations
of Jeddah,
Jedi nights for the Guardians,
peace,
justice,
and the old republic.
But buried within those principles,
we find some troubling and deeply unhealthy ideas about stoic masculinity.
In order to explain why I say that,
we first need to talk a little bit about the jet I ordered
itself.
I have a bad feeling about this.
I don't sense anything.
The Gin I order is an ancient organization of intergalactic warrior monks who
are framed as wise enlightened heroes with access to powerful mental abilities.
You don't need to just see his identification
as originally presented in star wars episodes one through six.
The Gen I order is remarkably male dominated and male identified.
If you freeze frame and a few scenes you can catch brief glimpses of female
Jeddah in the background,
but all the jet I speaking roles in both trilogies are filled by men.
Yeah.
On the surface,
Janai nights appear to be a welcome alternative to more traditional male action
hero archetypes.
I'm looking for a great warrior,
forced not to make one great.
They're soft,
soft-spoken,
careful,
deliberate and cool.
Under pressure,
they practice meditation and rely on Intelligence and dexterity over physical
strength,
but even though the Jetta I are in some ways presented as different from the
expected Hollywood fair,
that doesn't necessarily mean they represent a positive version of masculinity.
George Lucas drew on a wide variety of cinematic sources when of his star wars
mythology.
The elements he borrowed from the Samurai movies of Akira.
Kurosawa are fairly self evident.
Yeah,
but when asked about his inspiration for the jet,
Lucas most often cites the US marshals of the old west is all the boys on them
has filtered through Hollywood movies.
I'll give you a five seconds to unbuckle your guns and it's not hard to see why.
In the name of the Galactic Senate of the Republic you're under arrest like the
upstanding lawmen from classic Westerns.
The Jed,
I are framed as a rugged stoic warriors who bring order to a lawless land.
This party's over,
Jed.
I don't strike first,
but if provoked,
they're proficient in the use of violence and capable of a rather extreme level
of brutality.
Jed,
I business.
Go back to your drinks.
Most of what we know about Gi philosophy we gleaned from the words of Yoda and
Obi wan Kenobi.
We know for instance that Jedi masters admonish recklessness and advocate
patients that fit your
every judge.
I crave not bs thing.
Ooh,
I read nurse.
But the real heart of Gi Dogma,
the teachings that are given,
the most importance have to do with emotions
in star wars.
Uh,
Janai is worst.
Enemies are not agents of the dark side.
His true enemies are his own emotions.
And because of that,
Jan,
I masters teach that the expression of emotion must always be suppressed.
The tenants of Jen I philosophy are left a little bit vague in the original
trilogy to really get specifics.
We have to travel back to the beginning.
Long before he dawned the mask of Darth Vader and can Skywalker is instructed to
wear another mask,
a mask of emotional and vulnerability in the phantom menace.
Uh,
young Anagen is identified as being forced sensitive players.
You again,
as a result,
he's taken away from his mom and his home planet to be trained as a Jedi
warrior.
Okay.
But when he's presented to the Jedi Council,
he's soundly rejected.
And the reason that Yoda gives for rejecting this nine year old boy is because
he's too emotional.
And why is he deemed to emotional?
Well,
it's because he admits that he misses his mother sat through you.
We can his mother who,
let's remember the gin I have just left in slave to to an unscrupulous junk
dealer in another part of the galaxy.
Being mindful of your feelings,
your thoughts dwell on your mother.
I miss her
afraid to lose her.
I think what does that got to do with anything?
Everything
is the path to the dark side.
I want to underscore the message being presented here and it comes.
Feelings of pain and loss are understandable and completely normal,
but instead of getting the emotional support that he so desperately needs,
this child is instead publicly shamed for expressing his feelings of grief and
sadness has sense,
much fear in you
and that's because emotional detachment is valued above all else in the jet I
order young Jedi are instructed to sever all close emotional connections to the
people they care about.
They must learn to hide their feelings from others to deny their emotional
selves and to always present a stoic exterior to the world.
Now at this point,
some star wars fans may be saying to themselves,
hold on,
I thought the Jed I,
we're all about feelings.
Strategize with your feelings.
Well,
not exactly Jedi masters do encourage students of the forced to trust their
intuition.
Let go conscious
act on instinct.
Think of it as a jet eyes,
sixth sense,
but they're also sternly warned to always keep their emotions buried deep
inside.
To be clear,
Jedi masters don't push stoicism on boys to be cruel or malicious.
Truly wonderful.
The mind of a child is they like many well meaning.
People in the real world firmly believed that boys need to disassociate from
their feelings and learn to tough it out in silence,
but regardless of the intentions leaving young men emotionally abandoned is
psychologically damaging and extremely unhealthy.
Author Bell Hooks describes this emotional hardening process in a book I highly
recommend entitled the will to change men,
masculinity and love.
The way we turn boys into men is through injury.
We sever them from their mothers.
Research tells us far too early.
We pull them away from their own expressiveness,
from their feelings,
from their sensitivity to others.
The very phrase be a man means suck it up and keep going.
Disconnection is not fallout from traditional masculinity.
Disconnection is masculinity by what she means.
That emotional disconnection has become synonymous with manhood itself.
Viewed through this lens.
Yodas words the young antiquing Skywalker are downright traumatizing.
We start to see the fallout from July teachings can attack of the clones where
we rejoin anagin as a bratty entitled teenager,
a teenager who's still struggling to follow the imperative of emotional
detachment,
even though he's been clearly instructed to forget about his mother and a
consensus that something is wrong
and his concern for her wellbeing transforms into premonition filled nightmares.
You look tired.
I don't sleep well anymore
because of your mother
and it can still isn't getting the emotional support that he needs.
I don't know why I keep dreaming about it.
Instead,
he's just meant to put his mother's suffering out of his mind.
Dreams pass and time
as a general in training,
he must strive to become an autonomous,
detached emotional island.
Be Mindful of your thoughts and again,
they betray you.
You've made a commitment to the jet.
I order a commitment not easily broken.
Manikins inability to bury his anxieties about his mom's wellbeing is seen as a
manifestation of his emotional volatility.
In fact,
throughout the prequels,
men's expression of grief is consistently demonized.
I miss you
so much.
Crying in particular is framed as evidence of a dangerous loss of control.
I,
whenever we see tears from antiquing,
it's always meant to represent his weakness of character and communicate to the
viewer that he's being seduced by the dark side.
Contrary to popular opinion,
men burying their feelings is not a sign of strength.
Real strength is having the courage to ask for help.
The courage to talk about your feelings,
the courage to risk being vulnerable in front of others,
but the Jedi order for bids,
any of that
are you allowed to laugh?
Thought that was forbidden for debt.
Attachment for a minute.
Possession is forbidden.
Compassion,
which I would define us,
unconditional central Georgia has life.
George Lucas likes to say that the Jed I are compassionate,
but there's an important caveat there.
The Gi practice and impersonal detached,
Birdseye view sort of compassion one that's decidedly unconcerned with the
suffering of individual people,
which is one of the Jetta I don't lift.
A finger can try to help an Akins and slaved mom despite their considerable
influence and,
and it can longs for human contact.
But since July Dogma prohibits attachments,
he must satisfy his emotional needs in secret.
He conceals his marriage to pat may and hides her pregnancy from everyone around
him.
When Anik and attempts to seek advice from Yoda about his continuing nightmare
is in revenge of the sith he does so without revealing his secret concern for
the safety of his wife and unborn children and he gets what might be the worst
advice in the history of the galaxy.
The fear of loss is a path to the dark side.
Death is a natural part of life.
Rejoice for those around you who transformed into the force.
Mourn them.
Do not miss them.
Attachment leads to jealousy,
the shadow of greed.
That is what must I do.
Mastery over.
Train yourself to let go of everything you fear to lose.
I just need to pause here for a moment because although Yodas words are framed
as a form of enlightened wisdom,
his advice is truly unhinged.
Had Yoda been interested in actually helping antiquing?
There are a whole host of things he could've done.
First.
He could have acknowledged and validated Anticon spheres.
He could have listened and shown a little bit of empathy and he could've
encouraged and akin to seek counseling for his obvious trauma and anxiety.
But Jed,
I orthodoxy prevents Yoda from doing any of that.
So instead,
antiquing is essentially told to stop caring so much and that if something
tragic were to happen to his loved ones,
he should just be happy about it.
Now,
it's true that men,
being possessive of women is a negative thing,
but that's not what's happening in anacon story in this scene.
He is just afraid for the safety of his family,
which brings us to one of the central themes in July.
Philosophy in both trilogies,
fear is framed as the gateway drug to the dark side.
It's the emotion that we hear Yoda warn against in the most ominous of tones.
Skew is the path to the dark side.
In reality,
of course,
fear like most human emotions serves an important physiological function.
It can help keep us safe and healthy.
You'd think a quasi spiritual organization that preaches balance in all things
would understand that.
But did I teachings leave no room for such subtleties?
And that's because Jen I philosophy is constructed around what I'd call an
emotional domino.
Theory is the path to the dark side.
Fear leads to anger.
Anger leads to hate,
hate leads to suffering.
Setting aside George Lucas's misappropriation of some spiritual concepts that
originate in Asia,
that formula is incredibly reductive and also not how emotions work.
What being afraid is not a slippery slope to all consuming evil.
And yet this emotional domino affect theory is core to the judge I belief
system.
They believe that young men are inherently volatile and if they succumb to one
intense emotion,
it will spark and inevitable chain reaction that leads to hatred like knocking
over a set of dominoes.
So let's see if we can untangle some of the twisted logic here.
Even though Yoda starts his bizarre equation with fear.
That's not the first domino in the chain.
The fear of loss is a path to the job site.
Notice that he's warning about fear of loss,
which he says stems from emotional attachments to other people.
This is why the jet I order expressly for bids,
romance and prohibits its members from having families.
Just so we're clear on what that means.
According to the I,
it's loving relationships with another person that leads men down the path to
evil,
afraid to lose her.
I think what does that got to do with anything?
Everything.
Although the jet I caution against emotional attachments in general,
it's close relationships with women in particular that are framed as the most
dangerous.
This has made a specially evident in the prequels,
this too,
where emotional bonds with women are framed as something that eats away at a man
sanity and indirectly drives men to fits of uncontrollable rage.
By the end of episode three,
it's been made abundantly clear that antiquing turns into Darth Vader because
he's unable to suppress his love for the women in his life.
Embedded in that plot point is a toxic idea.
That emotional intimacy and connection with women represents a loss of control
for men.
The framing of relationships with women as something that drains men of their
autonomy,
their power or their control is not a new storytelling device.
It goes all the way back to Samson and Delilah and beyond.
Though in George Lucas's version,
women don't actively sabotage men.
Instead,
they serve as the impetus for men's instability and that message that women are
the catalyst for men's loss of control is part of a deeply sexist worldview.
It's an especially pernicious myth because it fosters resentment towards women
and also encourages men to view healthy expressions of emotional intimacy with
suspicion.
For those of us who grew up as fans of the original trilogy,
it can be tempting to pin all the blame for this on the prequels.
Unfortunately,
there are echoes of everything we've been talking about here in Luke story as
well.
Again,
it's like poetry.
So if they ride,
every stands are kind of rhymes with the last one in return of the Jedi,
Obi wan Kenobi articulates the second reason the jet.
I demand that boys tightly control their emotions,
feelings deep done.
They bill.
Your credit couldn't be made to serve the emperor.
He Instructs Luke To Bury His love for layer because if he doesn't,
his feelings will be seen as a weakness.
Yes,
you'll betray you and we'll make him vulnerable to the manipulation and control
of other men
sis.
So
sister,
your feelings have now betrayed her too.
If you will not do the dark side,
then perhaps she will.
The emperor,
his master plan for turning and akin to the dark side follows the same logic.
Learn to know the dark side of the force and you will be able to save your wife
from certain.
It revolves around exploiting the weakness of antiquing.
His love for Pat May
and the narrative lessons for both protagonists.
Closely Mirror hyper masculine socialization in the real world,
men and boys are taught to hide their feelings because we are told expressing
vulnerability demonstrates weakness
and leaves them open to being manipulated or dominated by their rivals.
Control.
I think it's instructive to talk a little bit about why Anna can becomes Darth
Vader while his son remains a hero like antiquing.
Luke's Janai training includes the demand that he buried his emotions,
sever his attachments and abandoned his friends and like an Akin Luke doesn't
always follow the instructions of his teachers.
You must face
again.
I can't kill my own father.
Yeah,
then the emperor has already won.
The difference is that unlike his father,
Luke doesn't take the generic orthodoxy surrounding emotional detachment to
heart.
When an Akins emotions bring him into conflict with Jed I teachings he feels
deeply ashamed and tries to hide his relationships.
Luke,
on the other hand,
openly vocalizes his objections and defies both Yoda and Obi wan.
The training I keep division out of my head.
They're my friends.
I got to help them.
You Mush not glow,
but Han and Leia will die if I don't.
Patience and sacrifice on and layer if you honor what they fight for it.
Yes.
Are to fire up the converters.
He chooses to embrace his attachment to his friends,
chooses to try to save his father and critically chooses not to always bottle up
his vulnerable feelings.
When you really think about it,
Luke Skywalker is at his very best when he doesn't follow the path of the Jedi.
Yeah.
The belief that emotional disconnection is an essential step for boys on their
journey into manhood is a common one,
but following that path leads to a life of loneliness,
emotional dysfunction,
and anger.
Let's return once more to bell hooks.
Anger often hides depression and profound sorrow.
Depression often masks the inability to grieve.
Males are not given the emotional space to grieve.
There still being taught to keep it in and worse to deny that they feel like
crying,
unable to cope with the loss of emotional connection.
Boys internalize the pain and mask it with indifference or rage.
Yeah.
That passage gives us some clues as to the real reason why Anna can Skywalker
can't handle grief or loss.
He's been well trained by the Jedi to stipel his emotions and hide his
vulnerabilities and he's never learned how to process or work through painful
emotions in healthy ways.
The results are as predictable as they are dysfunctional and it can is left
completely unprepared for tragedy
and like so many young men in our own culture,
he eventually lashes out in anger and leaves behind a trail of horrific
violence.
Jed,
I philosophy gets it entirely backwards.
Emotional detachment doesn't prevent men from turning to the dark side.
Emotional detachment is the cause of men turning to the dark side.
In the end,
it's the Jetta and their philosophy of emotional detachment that's ultimately
responsible for the creation of Darth Vader.
In this video,
I focused on the Jetta.
I as presented in George Lucas's six feature films because they provide the
foundation upon which everything else in the star wars university is built.
The star wars cinematic universities.
Now,
thankfully out of George Lucas,
his hands,
and it'll be interesting to see how Disney handles the GI I mythos moving
forward,
especially now that we have our first female I with her own trilogy.
Hopefully ray won't be forced down the same path of emotional detachment as her
male predecessors.
The stoic imperative is expected of men in our society,
but it's an unhealthy ideal for people of any gender.
As we've discussed in this video,
listening to the teachings of Yoda and Obi wan is a guaranteed recipe for
creating lonely,
angry,
broken people like all human beings,
men and boys need love.
They need affection,
they need emotional support,
and they need opportunities to openly communicate their feelings.
The glorification of emotional detachment is one of the more pervasive and
insidious messages about masculinity in popular media.
And it's something that we as men need to organize a rebellion against.
I hope you enjoyed that video.
Uh,
these essays take an enormous amount of time to produce.
That one took about three months,
all told.
So if you like these long form video essays,
please consider going over to Patrion and helping to fund the project there.
There's also a link to paypal in the description below.
Next month,
we'll be talking about one of Hollywood's favorite
for tropes stocking as romance.